hey this is Charles Barkley and this is
what are you eating
[Music]
it's just like a salt the heart or what
find out okay so what'd I just do well
do you mean I'm gonna taste it that's
like some type of fruit it's not an
apple it starts to be [ __ ] I'm just
kidding I'm just kidding just kidding
just kidding America don't ever lose
your sense of humor I've had this before
it it's not one of my papers what is it
bananas oh my god that's why I hate
bananas oh yeah that's like the greatest
invention ever
push the clean doughnut I would never
miss this just like the only real donut
yeah that was easy I can't even tell the
difference in donut brother man this is
some nasty stuff whatever this smells
nasty oh man this is some nasty fish
stuff
see this is nasty I don't eat fish man
this is nasty what is this see we oh man
that's so okay I mean it's not it's
close enough to fish it's like some type
of candy like it's not as good as your
little swedish fish
yep it starts out sweet then it goes
sour sweet sour roll roll roll sweet
sour roll did I said it I said roll not
rook I don't know I probably that's okay
not the first time you screwed up sweet
tart candy now hash kids
sour patch kids okay well this is just
disgusting
it reminds me of Greek yogurt which I
hate it's part of the yogurt family I
want to say but it's nasty it's not
yogurt this ending yogurt family is what
I said no it's not good whatever it is
what is it so mac and cheese baby food
Oh
[Music]
hmm some type of donut cake it's not bad
to use a little more sugar was the
reason people eat desserts they don't
won't help to desserts mmm that's
something in the middle of it um some
type of I want to say
doden a cake with something in the
middle of mixture you know I don't know
what it is Twinkie
oh really interesting I haven't had a
Twinkie in many years it's bring back
good memories not bad